people across cultures and across
millennia they've always had the
instinct to stay connected to the dead
and they have pulled the available
technologies of the day into service to
try to get hold of the dead but now
we're at a point where the dead live in
the tech already it's easy to connect to
the dead because they're everywhere
nearly everyone knows someone who had a
Facebook account and passed away it was
a friend of mine who recently took their
own life and I found out purely by
reading statuses and comments on images
from several accounts of social media we
can all identify with the experience and
it's it's kind of an a new experience
that we haven't had before in the
pre-digital era I got a direct message
from someone saying hey are you are you
gonna come to the service tonight and
that was really strange because again
like I say all of the interaction around
their very real passing happened purely
in the digital
if the dead person is leaving behind
this hugely multifaceted online
footprint it gets in the way of people
doing that process it's like okay here's
the durable biography it's 2,000 pages
and it's really complicated
you know and here's the image the person
presented to the world and here's their
search history somebody can go off on a
detective trail trying to kind of work
out who was this person and so you could
open a door and you can go down and keep
on finding stuff and finding a stuff in
the fight except that's the kind of not
letting go that can then maybe be
deleterious and not allow people to rest
and their grief for someone servers are
filling up with data about dead people
[Music]
and if you keep archiving data sooner or
later you will have to ask yourself the
question what data should we save and
what should be deleted when everything
is is online when the majority of what
we do becomes virtual it will be maybe
one of the most important questions that
people can to deal with
we should think about what we leave
behind on the web as part of who we are
[Music]
I opted for deletion of my google data
through an active Account Manager so if
I'm inactive for 18 months on any Google
service including search engine all of
my data and Google will be deleted
people maybe need to be saving in orders
that other people can digitally curate
their memories their their digital sales
up after they die and maybe that's a
future job that people could do I'm
going to be managing what I put online
with what I feel is most important and
most valuable and in keeping it that
reduced keeping it that curated keeping
it that edited so that for one it's not
going to be that avalanche of things
that my descendants inherit sever from
any kind of thought about my own death
I'm just always the way and I like
sharing poetry you're just kind of like
pity thoughts it's going to live on
you